يمكن لـ [الموسيقى]
في الواقع أن تكون كذلك بالفعل
وهي تفوز بالمنافسة في المزيد
والمزيد من الأسواق حول العالم أينما
ترى أن لديك إطارًا سياسيًا تمكينيًا
لديك
هيكل تنظيمي يشجع المستثمرين على
القدوم إلى السوق الآن الذي نراه  في
المزيد والمزيد من الأسواق حول العالم
، تتنافس مصادر الطاقة المتجددة بشكل مباشر
مع أرخص الأحافير في الواقع ،
نتوقع أنه بحلول عام 2030 ، سيكون أرخص
شكل لتوليد الطاقة على الشبكة هو
الطاقة المتجددة ، أعتقد أنك تعرف
متى بدأت هذه التحولات في
الحدوث.  يحدث ذلك في الواقع بسرعة كبيرة ،
لذا إذا نظرت إلى الوراء ونظرت إلى
الانتقال من الهواتف الأرضية إلى
الهواتف المحمولة أو نظرت من خلال
أجهزة الكمبيوتر والهواتف الذكية التي تعرفها عن مدى
سرعة تطوير هذه
التقنية وإزاحة التقنيات السابقة ،
أعتقد أنها يمكن أن تكون سريعة جدًا و
التغيير المدمر للغاية الذي سيأتي لكنه
سيبدأ بقطاع الكهرباء
[الموسيقى]
جيدًا ، لقد نما بسرعة كبيرة في الماضي
خمس سنوات إذا نظرنا إلى الكهرباء
في السنوات الخمس الماضية ، فإن جميع
القدرات العالمية المضافة الجديدة في قطاع الطاقة العالمي
تأتي معظمها من
الطاقة المتجددة وهذا يحدث
في المزيد والمزيد من البلدان ،
إنه يحدث بمعدل أسرع من
من قبل وأعتقد أن
ما سنراه هو مستقبل حيث ستصبح
إضافة قدرة الطاقة المتجددة لتوليد الطاقة
الشكل السائد
للتوليد في العقد القادم أو نحو ذلك
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه من المثير جدًا رؤية
ما يحدث  في العالم العربي
اليوم ، نعلم أن الإمارات العربية
المتحدة كانت من أوائل المحركات في
مجال الطاقة المتجددة ، فلديها بعض
المشاريع الطموحة للغاية التي تم تنفيذها
في أبو ظبي ودبي والتي
تولد الطاقة بتكلفة منخفضة جدًا ، لذا فإن
الإمارات العربية المتحدة بالتأكيد واحدة  من بينها ، رأينا أيضًا
استثمارات في الأردن
تجعل أحد أفضل اقتصادات ekkada أداءً
في الاستثمار في الطاقة المتجددة.
h الطاقة الشمسية وطاقة الرياح على مدى السنوات
القليلة الماضية ، فقد وضعوا هدفًا يتمثل
في 52 ٪ من مصادر الطاقة المتجددة بحلول عام 2030
وبدأت مصر الآن في الاستثمار في
مصادر الطاقة المتجددة بطريقة مثيرة جدًا للاهتمام على
نطاق واسع والتي أعتقد أنها بدأت
في تغيير المعادلة في
قطاع الطاقة المحلي